let's jump into this first story so
definitely we're going to get to
i want to you know get into the nitty
gritty of wikipedia because i have rag i
was basically ragging on wikipedia and
then you tweeted at me and i was like
yes let's talk about you know wikipedia
but we do have some breaking news that i
want to get into first from the rap
twitter permanently suspends project
veritas's james o'keefe
o'keeffe says he plans to sue the
platform for defamation following the
suspension
twitter permanently banned james o'keefe
thursday the project veritas founder
spent the preceding days posting videos
taken of a cnn employee
without that employee's knowledge in
keeping with his organization's practice
of coverted coverted covertly recorded
content
copy editor guys but in violation of
twitter's policy
o'keefe who had over 900 000 followers
at the time of his suspension
told the wrap that he plans to sue the
social media platform quote
the account you referenced james o'keefe
iii was permanently suspended for
violating the twitter rules
on platform manipulation and spam a
twitter spokesperson confirmed
as outlined in our policy on platform
manipulation and span
you can't mislead others on twitter by
operating fake accounts
and you can't artificially amplify or
disrupt conversations
through the use of multiple accounts
that's an interesting statement to make
because now james could sue for
defamation assuming it's not true
the rep declined to elaborate on the
claim that o'keefe was running multiple
fake accounts
including how many he was running or how
they were used in a statement
o'keefe said i am suing twitter for
defamation because they said
i james o'keefe operate fake accounts
this is false
this is defamatory and they will pay
section 230 may have protected them
before
but it will not protect them from me the
complaint will be filed
monday that reminds me of uh watchmen
you guys yeah
have you ever seen the movie watchmen
yeah i have or read the comic at all
i think i did once a little bit of it
anyway it just reminds me of when
rorschach is in prison and he's
like i'm not trapped in here with you
you're trapped in here with me
and it's not a good one for one analogy
but basically
they started to fight with somebody who
was looking for him well i shouldn't say
james is looking for a fight but ready
to win a war
yeah he only goes to war when he's going
to win that's what i've learned about
james o'keefe he's been going to war
he's been going to battle i should say
to win this war so you may have heard he
sued the new york times oh yeah
now now he's also going to sue cnn so
here's the next bit of this story
which will get us into the talk of
censorship and fake news and things like
that
james is according to newsweek james
o'keefe to expand his war on cnn with
lawsuits more video
controversial undercover journalist and
scourge of the left so saith newsweek
james o'keefe appears to be waging a
full-scale war on cnn
that includes not only the undercover
videos he's known for but also a series
of planned lawsuits against the news
network
and its anchors over issues that may not
even involve him or his nonprofit
organization
o'keefe told newsweek he will soon sue
cnn and two of its journalists brian
stelter
and anna cabrera for defamation and
report about twitter permanently banning
project vertos
the february segment featured cabrera
accusing veritas of promoting
misinformation
and calling a group of conservative
actionists activists
none of which o'keefe says is true
twitter reportedly banned project
veritas
over an anti-doxing policy after the
group confronted a facebook executive
outside of his home
in the same february segment stelter
claimed project veritas violated
multiple rules
meanwhile o'keefe posted video of cnn so
this i think most people are familiar
with
here's a here's a statement from james
he said we are suing cnn
brian stelter and anna cabrera and we
are going to represent others in
defamation suits against cnn
we are going to launch a division for
lawsuits
o'keeffe told newsweek i wonder where he
got that idea i like that idea
i believe he we uh brainchild of that
here on the show well
his is a little different but uh when he
was on the show we talked about the
people's defamation defense fund or
something
to that effect so when these news
outlets start writing fake stories
there is an advocate to protect you from
the media the smears
as we get into this uh this space where
everyone's a public figure
you know uh it becomes harder and harder
to sue for instance nicholas sandman in
the covington catholic case
they argued he was an involuntary public
figure because someone filmed him
standing on stairs
and now he was in the public spotlight
it's insane we've come to that point
where basically no one is protected
anymore so
if project veritas is doing it i'm
stoked this guy's
you know winning swings and battles
there's a huge
need for it and um i uh
i can only say and that uh they
eventually
um help give the same treatment to
um wikipedia frankly there's been
so many people who have been defamed by
wikipedia
and there hasn't been um any recourse
i i remember back in 2006 i think it was
or seven
something like that um john siegenthaler
senior um the father of john
siegenthaler jr
um i believe he's a co-founder of usa
today or so
something like that um in the tennessean
he was the the
the publisher or the editor anyway very
distinguished
gentleman um elderly retired
and um he you know
they had essentially defamed him by
saying that he
had you know gone to live
in in the soviet union back in the day
or something like that um and it was bad
and it was totally false
and he he basically criticized me over
the phone
back then um and i felt bad
i really did and it's like i took i took
his personal responsibility and that's
that's
one of the things that that made me
realize that you know real people are
harmed by this sort of thing
when did you uh so look you know i guess
in the context of james and all this
yeah he's i think he's someone who has
seen
the lies and the smears firsthand yeah
for a very long time
sure i mean so i went to wikipedia and i
looked up project veritas
and it says definitively they produce
deceptively edited videos
and i'm like what's the source for this
and i click it it actually links to like
24 different articles
the problem is the word deceptive is an
opinion not a statement of fact
but wikipedia is an encyclopedia
supposedly showing you
the facts so i think for james he just
finally was sick of it and said let's go
to war and start fighting back which he
is
i'm curious i mean that story about this
guy from here today that was that was
the first moment you realized that you
know
defamation was occurring or oh i i of
course i knew
that there was defamation going on
before that but it's he really brought
it home to me because he was actually a
victim
and he was a distinguished old southern
gentleman
um and uh and he was criticizing me
personally um so that that's what
really made it hit home it didn't matter
at the time that i was
i was actually starting a competing
website i still took responsibility
for for uh wikipedia so
i don't i don't understand why james
hasn't launched a nuke against wikipedia
right now
it says on wikipedia project veritas
purpose disinformation wow
outright yes there's a far right
activist group
the group produces deceptively edited
videos no
uh so i think this is that's that's what
it really damages
his reputation um and and the thing is
wikipedia does that to a lot of people
now right and they're hiding behind
section 230 they're hiding behind that
that protection and there is absolutely
no recourse
that anybody has due to the legal
framework in which wikipedia operates
i've i've known about this
for a long time you know and i just
i i have wondered you know how what
what's gonna actually
what's it gonna take to change and maybe
it's somebody with relatively deep
pockets
and lots of rich friends actually going
after them
in a in a big way and you you don't seem
particularly
well i haven't known you that long but
you don't seem particularly biased right
you're you're i think you tweeted in
defense of james o'keefe on
about him getting suspended um
uh sure well in defense of him being
suspended
i'm sorry i'm sorry in defense of his uh
of him yeah
in relation to the suspension saying
james should not have been suspended
well absolutely yeah i think he
shouldn't have been
suspended just recently on twitter but i
mean i wouldn't agree that i'm
that i'm unbiased well what i mean to
say is
uh we all have our biases yeah but
you're not you're not
you don't appear to be a tribalist like
defending the conservatives
so that's why i think it's important to
make the distinction we're talking about
what wikipedia was supposed to be
okay um i'm i can only imagine what your
original vision for it was and how it
strayed from that
that's my opinion of what can you tell
us about it like when did you
start it how many of you were there and
what was the vision
right well um uh i i don't know how long
do you
want me to go into this because we have
a two hour show
tell me 10 minutes i'm thinking about it
when you're 17 like where did it come
from
okay well i won't go into too much
detail but i'll give you
because this is a big enough platform
probably a lot of people who are
listening to this have
not heard the story um so i'll just i'll
just tell it again um
basically i got to know jimmy wales in
the mid-1990s he
ran a discussion group for
fans of inrant really oh yeah
wow um and well he used to be a
hardcore objectivist slash libertarian
um and well we can talk about that later
whatever
um and and i actually uh i got to
know him a little bit i wouldn't say
that we ever became
friends but we were good acquaintances
and we were friendly
um and i actually met him in person a
couple of times back in the mid 1990s
and
then about i guess at the end of 1999
early 2000 um i was
deciding what i was going to do with
this website that i had called sanger's
review
of y2k news reports oh wow
yeah um and uh
i made some proposals uh
and sent it out to different
acquaintances he was one and he said
why don't you come to work for me i want
to start this
free public contributed encyclopedia
built on a mod the model of
like linux so open source
except it's not open source it's open
content and he gave me stuff to read
i said yes i mean this is like i
actually
have to answer your question dreamed
about things that i could do with the
philosophy degree if i didn't want to
become
a professor which eventually i decided
not to do back in like 1996
um so uh and one of them was
was an encyclopedia editor and here
somebody is offering me the
the opportunity to start my own
encyclopedia and
yeah it was really cool um so that was
my job basically
to start something um he he had the
domain name was called newpedia and i
organized um a a group of hundreds of
phds
um and it was almost like organizing a
whole college
really um because there were different
departments and there were quite a few
different people in the different
departments and so forth
but um i sort of
uh worked with these people and being
academics
they like things being very regimented
and top down
and that's the system that we ended up
with um negotiating with them we ended
up with a system that had seven steps
and it was a lot of work to get an
article through that system
so in the end um
we realized it actually i shouldn't say
in the end close to the beginning
actually
um we realized we were well agreed that
there needed
something um we needed something
to make it a lot easier for people to
contribute
just the average person so i cast around
different ways of of allowing other
people to contribute
and um i uh
eventually um a friend of mine and this
this
was january 2nd of 2001
um he told me about wiki wiki software
the wiki wiki web that's the original
wiki
um portland pattern repository it's a
repository of
software programming patterns um
and then um that same
concept of a sort of like a public
bulletin board
anybody could write anything they want
and edit anything
and yet somehow magically it works okay
and he explained how and why it could
work
and i said wow this actually might be a
way we should try this out because the
software was free
so i that same evening i went
back and i think ben ben kovitz is the
name of
my friend we had had a mexican dinner
and in which he explained all this to me
i went back um
to my apartment and wrote out a
um a one-page proposal to jimmy wales
and said can you guys um
install the software for me to use and
and uh
so a couple of days later that was done
and so i just went to
work like describing what a wiki
encyclopedia would be like
um and it would it changed
the culture it wiki wiki's had been
around for six years before that so
there was already a sort of internet
culture
surrounding wikis so we had to sort of
change that
and reappropriate not just the software
but also
the um the the culture
for the purpose of creating an
encyclopedia
um and uh i was just
amazed that like after the first uh
month it despite a lot of people being
very
skeptical about um it possibly working
especially
the the relatively straight-laced um
phd uh editors of new pedia
um they they didn't like the idea at all
and and sort of jimmy wales himself was
kind of in
in their corner in the beginning um
and i said well okay we're going to just
we're going to have to
relaunch this because originally it was
going to be the new pedia wiki
right it was a different it was a a
different
um uh course of uh
or source of content for newpedia that's
what it was supposed to be
um and i said okay well if you guys
don't want it associated with the
newpedia brand then we'll just
we'll just relaunch it under its own
domain name and i came up with with
wikipedia
we registered that originally it was
wikipedia.com
because the whole enterprise was started
by baumus
bombus inc doesn't exist any longer
um and they were a startup of the
uh of the old.com boom the late 1990s
and
they were well funded through uh ads
and then that basically the funding
disappeared
it even as wikipedia was taking off even
that
in that first year
so basically in that in that first year
everyone was amazed at how
well it was working even just like a
month into it
and people were just excited to
participate
and we observed after a few months
how google would spider all the articles
the new articles
in wikipedia um and
the there was a sort of like a
a stair um graph
of the growth of wikipedia after the
google spider hit the site
there would be a bump in both activity
on the site
and and just new people working on the
site
um and so it it looked like
a positive feedback loop and i thought
that that's just this can't be true it's
like too good to be true
but it was a it was truly a viral
phenomenon
um makes sense yeah the more articles
that get written
people search for things there's a
one-stop shop that has that subject so
google probably favored wikipedia as the
parent domain
and then whenever something got searched
for because wikipedia existed it treated
it probably like a news source
yeah you know you got it exactly that's
that's pretty much how it worked
um i i don't know perhaps at some point
google
um like made some special decisions that
that increased the overall
ranking of the wikipedia articles you
know the pagerank
algorithm was simpler back then and
and who knows it doesn't it doesn't
really matter
i think in the beginning it was just a
lot of
excitement about the whole idea
bright-eyed bushy-tailed i guess
very very optimistic for sure thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time